well capital ones the match yeah
Tiger a Peyton or feel and Brady man
that is a good match if I could choose
between Peyton Manning and Tom Brady two
of the Great's from their respective
craft to lead my team in a two-minute
drill no I gotta go c'mon man Peyton I
would pick Tom Brady
I'll respect the calm who's still still
playing I totally respect that so I
gotta go with my god Peyton Manning the
sheriff I play with a lot of guys who
play other sports and they always say
well you know I'm an athlete and I got
nothing to do with playing golf we
though they're two of the greatest
quarterbacks ever but I want to see the
golfers hit the shot under pressure on
national television in terms of the
capital ones the match go with Tiger
Tiger Woods y'all and and of course
Peyton if I had warned Tom and Phil I've
got Tiger impatient Tom doesn't really
have the time to devote to playing golf
whereas peyton has all the time in the
world
the guy's an extreme leader extreme
competitor
I can't pig Brady over Peyton because
Peyton took me to Augusta to woods P
Manning and on Sunday for Capital One's
d match I got Tiger and P mostly tiger